doctora blanca volé a muchas gracias por
estar con nosotros hoy en radio canadá
internacional cómo le va
muchas gracias por invitarme julia
gracias por estar acá porque tenemos
muchas preguntas para ustedes porque
como usted sabe hay muchas
preocupaciones con respecto a la vacuna
menos ahora que al principio que salió
la vacuna o que salieron y comenzaron a
salir las vacunas la de facer primero y
luego las que vinieron después pero
sigue habiendo preocupación por parte de
la gente con respecto a si es seguro
vacunarse o no 2 mi primera pregunta
sería una vez que las vacunas están
aprobadas por los ministerios de salud
de los países respectivos la gente o por
lo menos aquí en canadá a la gente tiene
razones de preocuparse por una
inoculación de este tipo
no el sistema regulatorio canadiense
para todas las medicinas es muy muy muy
estricto muy estricto problema los más
estrictos del mundo entonces sí que es
cierto que estas vacunas han sido
desarrolladas de una manera muy rápida
porque se necesitaban rápido y entonces
todo ese material de seguridad tenía que
ser evaluado muy rápido también y ahí
pues hoy con los comités involucrados
que tienen médicos y epidemiólogos
tienen gente especializada en como
asesorar la seguridad de medicamentos
antes que trabajar muy rápido pero a mí
me gustaría mandar un mensaje de calma
al respecto estas vacunas son seguras
para cuando se han sido aprobadas en
canadá y han sido probadas en casi
30.000 personas en el mundo es decir que
tenemos una tenemos una población en la
que ya se ha aprobado antes de llegar
aquí incluso
entonces en realidad el hecho de que ya
hayan que las compañías farmacéuticas
hayan hecho sus propias pruebas y que
posteriormente los ministerios de salud
las acepten es una seguridad de que no
hay digamos efectos efectos graves en la
salud de la gente
y que la gente puede tener confianza en
finalmente entonces ese refrán está
diciendo exactamente otra pregunta que
tendría yo que hacerle es con respecto a
los efectos y digamos sabemos que el
efecto principal que se busca ellos que
nos proteja de este colón a virus pero
los efectos secundarios que puede traer
una vacuna como ésta o como una de las
cuatro vacunas que han sido aprobadas
hay que recordar que aquí en canadá fue
la facer que fue aprobada moderna
astrazéneca y johnson johnson la última
reciente
entonces cuáles serían los efectos
secundarios principales que se han
observado en las las pruebas que se han
hecho bueno como la vacuna el objetivo
es producir una respuesta inmune es que
nuestro cuerpo reconozca estas proteínas
que normalmente están en el virus
lo más común es que se inflama un poco
la zona del pinchazo eso es lo más común
en algunas personas puede aparecer lo
que llamamos linfadenopatía que es que
uno de los nódulos linfáticos sea aún
inflamado un poco en la zona cercana a
donde el pinchazo ha ocurrido el día
siguiente o dos días siguientes algunas
personas experimentan un poquito de
fiebre como un síndrome nosotros
llamamos euro- gripal que parece una
gripe pero que no dura una semana como
una gripe sino un día un día y medio y
esto es más frecuente al segundo
pinchazo que al primero porque en el
primero el grupo está intentando
reconocer esta proteína en el segundo en
segundo un pinchazo el cuerpo ya tiene
ya sabe que esto es algo que tiene que
atacar y por lo tanto hay más hay más
respuesta inmune lo cual es bueno es
esta respuesta inmune obligatoria no no
todo el mundo va a tener efectos
secundarios con una vacuna
algunas personas mantener algunas no y
la mayor estos efectos secundarios son
muy muy ligeros muy leves no son la
mayor agente ni siquiera se toma un día
fuera del trabajo
recuerdo que cuando uno va a vacunar los
niños por ejemplo que tienen un sistema
de vacunación bien estricto y bien
constante durante varios años incluyendo
la adolescencia porque yo tengo hijos
adolescentes y hay hay vacunas que
todavía se les tienen que dar en la
adolescencia y los mis hijos y todos los
niños generalmente tienen una pequeña
reacción como dijiste de un poco de
fiebre sean un poco más cansados a veces
les duele un poco la cabeza pero nada
nada grave realmente generalmente son
reacciones normales digamos reacciones
aceptables y entonces es algo más o
menos semejante que sucede con esta
vacuna del del cómic game si esto es la
prueba de que la vacuna está funcionando
en el cuerpo de que el cuerpo está
reaccionando a una cosa extraña y
produciendo anticuerpos se produce una
inmunidad yo me daba la vacuna
y las más fáciles y efectivamente la
segunda dosis bueno
había un poco de rigidez muscular que no
se siente hace un poco pero nada más
nada más y también hay que recordar
frente a esos mínimos efectos
secundarios lo que estamos batallando no
crees que es un virus que mata gente que
tiene más exactamente exactamente
entonces en realidad los pequeños
riesgos valen la pena cuando se quiere
luchar contra una pandemia ahora otra
cosa que usted probablemente puede
explicarnos bien es la cuestión del
miedo porque hay miedo al asno y más que
más que el miedo a la vacuna como tal
también hay un miedo a las agujas hay
gente que tiene un miedo real a las
agujas a los pinchazos como tal de dónde
viene esto si es un interesante esto lo
llamamos una fobia simple que es cuando
él quiere miedo a una cosa solo y no en
lo demás muchas veces vienen de la
infancia de experiencias traumáticas con
el sistema de salud
a veces niños que han tenido operaciones
cuando eran muy pequeños y no les han
explicado lo que eran niños que a lo
mejor les han inyectado algún
medicamento no se lo han explicado y
entonces reaccionan masivamente y
recuerdan
son adultos también gente que es muy
ansiosa en general puede hacer pequeñas
fobias y desde luego es muy muy
importante si alguien tiene una fobia
este es de este tipo el doble con su
médico porque tienen curación es decir
puede ponerse en tratamiento en el caso
de si hay una persona que quiere ponerse
la vacuna pero tiene una fobia
importante a las agujas y lo
recomendaría que hablara con su médico
porque en el peor de los casos si no
puede ponerse en tratamiento porque no
tiene tiempo o no hay un buen consuelo
que la puede acoger es posible
simplemente darle un poquito de
medicación para ese día que se va a dar
la inyección para que esté un poquito
más tranquila o muy tranquilo y se puede
dar la inyección porque la inyección es
10 segundos es muy breve no y espero
hacer llegar mi recomendación la mejor
lo mejor es poner un tratamiento hay
otras terapias cognitivo conductual y
terapias de exposición en donde poco a
poco vas exponiendo cosas que te causan
el miedo por ejemplo un día pues
simplemente sostienes la
o la jeringuilla el otro día vas al
médico el otro día vas al médico y
cuestiones la jeringuilla
te vas exponiendo a esta cosa que te da
miedo hasta que eres capaz de llevarlo
ahora otro tema que me gustaría hablar
con usted es la otra pandemia la
pandemia de desinformación le han
llamado incluso info demia y eso ha
existido desde casi el principio de de
esta pandemia desde el inicio empezó a
circular y empezaron a circular a través
de los medios sociales una inmensa
cantidad de mensajes contradictorios
primero y después de mucho incluían
mucha desinformación muy pocas pruebas
que tiene que hacer la gente donde se
puede informar la gente para no caer en
las trampas de la desinformación o en
los miedos que a veces esa
desinformación transmite
esto es un problema muy grande y creo
que se ha detenido la verdad paloma
parte de este problema lo hemos creado
los médicos que nos explicamos bien que
no somos capaces de constantemente
reforzar y explicar conceptos biológicos
y médicos básicos
el wimax cual el hospital donde del
trabajo tiene información en todos los
lenguajes que se hagan en canadá
incluido español a traducida y además
sancionada por la gente que conoce una
situación con el comino y kings gente
que es expectante
la universidad de toronto y desde luego
yo les diría que acudieran a eso
güines college hospital con win tín a
útiles multilingüe es la realidad
se bajará en uno de estos son documentos
de dos o tres páginas son muy fáciles de
leer en el otro sistema funcionan muy
bien es el gobierno de ontario tiene
un sistema de información sobre el joven
line bien que funciona muy bien y que
tiene mucha información actualizada
hasta el día de hoy
entonces si quieres saber en términos de
números y es un buen recurso también
aquí estoy mostrando una de las una de
las es pues le podemos hacer una
plantilla de información donde viene
justamente cuáles son los efectos
secundarios de la vacuna qué efectividad
tienen bueno lo que estamos conversando
usted y yo ahora pero es un documento
office es un documento un boletín
informativo sobre esta vacunación que
fue producido por este germen scouts
este hospital donde éste trabaja
entonces como se refería decrépita nos
de nuevo la dirección para que la gente
pueda ir a alan y william girar güemes
con su hospital con line fin y después
es multilingüe y aparecen varias escalas
ya de memoria pero aparecen varias
varias lenguas y español está entre
ellas
ahora escuchaba en la mañana una
entrevista con una persona que trabaja
con ancianos con gente de la tercera
edad de algunas comunidades culturales
de la región de montreal en particular
pero me imagino que es exactamente lo
mismo en otras en otras zonas de canadá
él explicaba que la dificultad que están
teniendo ellos como grupo de ayuda es
llegar a esta gente para con la
información sobre la vacuna sobre dónde
inscribirse cómo tomar la cita que
significa tomarse la todo esto que
estamos conversando porque probablemente
que la gente que va a ver esta
entrevista entre usted y yo es gente que
tiene habilidades para ir al internet a
buscar la información a escuchar las
entrevistas pero hay otras personas o
que no conocen las lenguas y que
entonces justamente uno les dice women
hospital y no van y no saben cómo llegar
o tienen incluso dificultad de entender
el idioma francés o inglés entonces una
de las cosas que proponía es hacer más
un trabajo de campo
y realmente ir a las casas conversar
aunque esto significaría una una tarea
monumental entre las diferentes tareas
monumentales que tenemos en esta en esta
pandemia me imagino y es difícil sin
embargo
y yo creo que la comunidad es para
tenemos una cosa que nos beneficia y
quizás también esto es algo que se pueda
expandir a ciertas otras comunidades
como la italiana o la griega que somos
muy comunitarios que siempre somos muy
sociables entonces yo lo que
recomendaría es a la gente hispana que
es profesional habla bien inglés y en
francés y habla bien español que hagan
un poco de aurich ellos que se acuerden
de esa tía abuela que a lo mejor no
habla inglés o de esa vecina que saben
que llegó a canadá hace 20 años y la
está retirada y está un poco aislada del
mundo y se acercarán a ellos por
teléfono con la seguridad con con la
distancia social y les dijeran oye
has hablado con tu médico de cabecera
sobre la vacunación en estos momentos
por ejemplo los médicos de cabecera aquí
en andar yo están empezando ya a vacunar
a gente que es mayor de 80 años entonces
si alguien conoce a alguien que es mayor
de 80 años que se acerque a él y le
pregunte has hablado con tu médico de
cabecera quieres que le llamemos
y explicaremos con el contigo presente
para explicarle que bueno mejor no
puedes hablar el idioma pero qué quieres
vacunarse entonces a mí me gustaría como
que la comunidad hispana utilizará esa
calidad que tenemos de forma natural
para acercarse a otros también hay un
montón de instituciones aquí tenemos una
institución que se llama la agrupación
de gente que habla español en este tipo
de instituciones como también existe
esto cervantes etcétera son pueden
ayudar mucho porque ya tiene una
comunidad alrededor
eso sería ayudaría mucho si estas
instituciones se acercan a nosotros nos
permiten información sobre la vacuna de
forma que yo pueda hablar con ellos o
mis colegas pueden hablar con ellos
en nuestra comunidad en nuestro
beneficio
doctora blanca volea ha sido muy
interesante conversar con usted nos ha
esclarecido muchas muchas de nuestras
dudas supongo que la gente va a poder
estar más segura ahora de la efectividad
de la seguridad con la que pueden
acercarse a esta campaña de vacunación
que está ya en marcha en todo el
territorio canadiense
muchas gracias por invitarme hasta luego
[Música]